foreign
[Music]
get the hook inside
ES
[Music]
I'm flaming
Flames I won the game don't attack me
please
[Music]
I like him
come on
[Music]
I'm looking for the aliens in free stuff
with the pretty brown skin you'll
Negroes
please
[Music]
do it again
you're crazy
[Music]
[Applause]
I started to kind of feel like you know
I got a God in Me
[Music]
something got me feeling like a Klondike
everybody wanna take a big bite I'm
chocolate cold in the center Arthur but
lately I've been feeling like a winner
hey because the window didn't pass I'm
making big moves people kissing my ass
been a hot minute since I sat in the
class but I got my hand up baby give me
your pass on
[Music]
I'm not a better man but I feel like a
god
[Music]
[Applause]
snap your fingers
[Music]
just as long as I'm able let me make a
moves from the grave to the Cradle fool
feeding y'all use my lungs as a ladle
[Music]
like hey
cause I'm nervous
[Music]
thank you thank you so much Ted
we appreciate your time and why don't we
just say one more time I got to guide me
you ready two three four
y'all sing that with us okay
[Music]
that's right each and every one of you
baby
[Music]
I got a God in Me
[Applause]
[Music]